[Applause]
yay more previously on segments
do previously on segments make sense and
serve a purpose yes yes they do
will we keep sending them yes yes we
will no one will be seated during the 14
seconds of unzippering sequence
also the unzip reveals a great void of
nothing and i never realized how let
down a zipper could make me feel
defacing school property not my captain
america
i remember sneaking into this locker
room before
each game intentionally entering a men's
locker room when you don't even have
to this is the job john all of it is
it's always been in the job description
job description what would that even be
captain america must have delicious
juicy perfect buns
and be able to post for photos while
also able to kill unimaginable
terrorists from space with a shiny
circular winter sled
star spangled man with a plan and all
that roll commercials
isn't this soup it comes with
expectations bro
exactly it's no good stuff in a sock
down there
trust me also john has been doing the
captain america thing for two weeks now
so he's definitely heard all about the
expectations of the suit so why is lamar
in the scene
[ __ ] lamar you can't just punch your
head or problems anymore yeah the
climaxes of almost
every movie in this franchise would beg
to differ
[Music]
[Applause]
appreciate the new music i really do but
it's still masturbatory logoing and you
know how we feel about that around here
using a high school marching band to
introduce [ __ ] captain
america i'm sure they're very talented
but was lady gaga not available or
little big town or like kid rock i bet
kid rock was available
i don't think they're holding county
fairs currently
disrespecting your sensitive bits and
really the inguinal area in general
ah sudden sarah haynes disney could you
please stop masturbating for
five damn minutes was it really
necessary for walker to bring his
gun to this event yeah that and flags
tend to start majestically waving in the
wind
yeah i think that's just the wind but
what i do have
is guts uh something captain america
always had always needs to have and i'm
gonna need every ounce of it
if by guts you mean your stomach and
intestinal tract that only comes in
about 100 ounces think i'll take the
flashy gadgets and super strength please
good to see you too buck tv show called
the falcon and the winter soldier goes a
collective 58 minutes before it does
any falcon and winter soldiering what
could be bigger than this
this guy falcon is going to wave the
image of a bad guy needing a beatdown in
front of a
trained assassin in murder remission
currently struggling with a friend
identity crisis
is anyone thinking clearly today what
victory
androids aliens and wizards every time
we fight we fight one of the three
i mean except when you don't mysterio
whiplash obadiah stain yellowjacket
the winter soldier i read the hobbit
in 1937 when it first came out bucky is
like the guy who makes sure to point out
he first saw dave matthews at a college
frat party
no one cares and don't be like bucky
kids
i mean mainly because he's a killer but
the bragging thing is also bad
a sorcerer is a wizard without a hat
that's sorcerest
um also the dungeons and dragons players
handbook
clearly states on page 99 that a
sorcerer
is defined as nerd
i'm coming with you no you're not how
did bucky even get in here sure he's
been pardoned but
does that come with an all-access pass
to a military base of his choice
in case you confused it with munich
north dakota these linear communications
devices manage to stay intact after
diving out of the plane but
mine fall in my cereal bowl when i
sneeze how is that even fair
what is the point of this needless
sleeve ripping does the leather somehow
block the power of vibranium how many
jackets does bucky even go through
why not just take the damn thing off
entirely i have all of that on camera
you know that right but why falcon leaps
out of the plane to go on with his
mission unsure if bucky was even going
to follow or not why would he hang
around or
send his robot familiar to candid camera
bucky's plummet wait
is this supposed to be comic relief
you're doing the staring thing again
do you mean the thing where he looks at
something with his eyes
yeah total dick move hey come on man i'm
just messing with you come back
while on a highly sensitive mission that
requires stealth and focus falcon
decides that
this is the best time to be jovial read
the empty warehouse room in the middle
of a forest overseas on a secret mission
falcon
sure is lucky that these bad guys who we
assume do not want to be caught ignore
this very obvious kerfuffle
bucky runs up to this truck breaks the
door off and you're telling me that the
driver of truck 2 does
nothing there's no way they didn't see
him now yes
they know that the person in truck one
isn't a hostage but surely this is still
a less than ideal turn of events
and something at least hornworthy mind
you the masks do look very cool however
carly has already given herself away as
one of the thieves so does she really
need to put it on now
at this point she's just obstructing her
own vision
i always wanted to do that oh crap am i
starting to like bucky
sam is wasting his abilities here why
land on the truck and start a fist fight
when you can fly
just pick these guys up one at a time
and fling them into the forest okay
first of all close those doors before
your goods fly out of the truck second
why are the trucks still rolling down
the road like it's a normal caravan sure
we want to see a mobile fight on the top
of two trucks but would they want this
no they'd stop traffic kick some ass and
zippity-doo-dah down the road
third carly heard red wing coming and
was all ready to rivet to shreds
here comes a [ __ ] helicopter and
she's suddenly surprised
no just know hello girl kick your ass
setting aside show has time for this sam
didn't fare much better against
that little girl so maybe he should just
sexist the [ __ ] up
unlucky bucky stucky under a truckee
just let go
of the truck that was a bad idea
i'm not sure the show wants us rooting
for carly right now but i am
totally rooting for carly right now
super nice of that car to be completely
absent when lamar should have been run
over but
also appear to break his fall and how in
the hell
after 80 years or the eighth supersoul
just running loose
i mean one getting produced every 10
years i would guess
seems like pretty simple math falcon
it's 20 miles of the airport you guys
need a ride
no they really don't falcon can fly and
bucky can speed run why can't falcon
just fly them there
the script needs them in that vehicle
but sam and bucky are doing just fine on
their own
i see a guy hanging out of a helicopter
and tactical gear i need a lot more than
lamar hospital
sam would be the wizard android or alien
of tv since
they call you robin hood whoa whoa hold
your roll there
i'm not sure that you oh robin hood is
in the public domain
is there anything disney can't get their
hands on there is someone
that you should meet glad to see the
pronoun game survive decades of soviet
brainwashing
surprised they were able to find him
this easy makai is mostly associated
with an alias
you think you can wake up one day and
decide who you wanna be
wait are you saying i can't be an
astronaut but i just bought a new
goldfish bowl
none of these people are recording on
their cell phones yeah we did some field
ops back in the day
never heard field ops used as a
euphemism like that but okay
do whatever you got to do with them and
send them off to me this bullsh
blase attitude to therapy is still a
thing suppose that while you're sleeping
a miracle occurs when you wake up what
is something you would like to see that
would make your life
better i'll give all the sins back at
falcon says does crippling back pain
count because i got the spot right here
they're really smarts
in my miracle um he would he would talk
less
exactly what i was going to say isn't
that ironic only if you're using the
more set dictionary
and if he was wrong about you then he
was wrong about me bucky's feelings here
are heart-wrenching i wish i won't
comfort him and help him understand his
value outside of false equivalencies if
only there were a therapist that
actually
knew what the [ __ ] she was even doing
you know what doc
i don't have time for this and yet you
still spent the last five minutes
bantering and soul gazing
i'll see you outside careful that
tearaway sleeve will fall right off
i know that look what's wrong honestly
no disrespect to therapists everywhere
but she is
really bad at her job she brings in two
men with super abilities who need
professional guidance and has them just
stare at each other while tolerating
their childish banter here's an idea
have that
very clearly distraught ex-assassin sit
his ass down and do some of the hard
work of therapy
but you guys have rules of engagement
and all kind of authorizations you have
to get
we're free agents we're more flexible
how is that now
earlier walker said that the falcons
tech is government property and that he
himself was
kind of the government plus if falcon
hasn't been jetting around the globe on
an avengers jet so far he's been working
with the us military
i'm not so sure the falcon is a free
agent is what i'm saying
okay great now you've blocked the road
so you can just run back to the plane
and escape
what are you doing he blocked the road
and he's not far away he can still make
it back
what are you doing the plane's ready to
go and you can still make it
what are you doing you're just going to
run at them they've got
guns the five seconds it takes for them
to shoot you down won't make a
difference so you might as well run to
the plane
it's the most pointless sacrifice i've
ever seen on screen i just rewatched the
first transformers movie
we're gonna go see zemo gasp dramatic
reveal
intrigue callbacks end of episode
excitement
all i want is to fight on the top of a
train is that too
much to ask be yourself if you can't
love yourself
how the hell you gonna love somebody
else good morning
john john [ __ ] toast good morning
good afternoon good evening and good
night
[Music]
we're not playing no more we can't let
the same [ __ ] who are put back in
power after the blip win
you sound like you're from london
[Music]
get big ben parliament again
you